françaises français mes chers
compatriotes de l'hexagone d'outre-mer
et de l'étranger ce soir nous ne vivons
pas un 31 décembre comme les autres là
où dans nos villes et nos villages leur
est d'habitude au grand rassemblement
ils sont cette année interdit par
l'épidémie les places de nos communes
sont éteintes nos foyers moins joyeux
qu'à l'accoutumée l'année 2020 s'achève
donc comme elle s'est déroulée par des
efforts et des restrictions
et j'ai pleinement conscience par les
décisions que j'ai eu à prendre des
sacrifices que je vous ai demandé je
suis sincèrement convaincu que nous
avons fait les bons choix au bon moment
et je veux vous remercier de votre
civisme de cet esprit de responsabilité
collective par lequel nous avons sauvé
tant de vies et qui nous permettent
aujourd'hui de tenir mieux que beaucoup
face à l'épidémie en votre nom j'ai ce
soir une pensée pour les 64 mille
victimes de ce virus
leurs familles et leurs proches des
parents des amis des pans entiers de
l'imaginaire français nous ont quitté
ces derniers mois oui cette année 2020 a
été difficile elle nous a rappelé nos
vulnérabilités
elle a été encore plus injuste pour les
plus fragiles mais ensemble nous en
sortons encore plus unis et en ayant
beaucoup appris j'ai aussi une pensée
pour tous nos compatriotes vivent dans
la précarité parfois la pauvreté pour
qui la crise que nous traversons rend le
quotidien plus difficile encore je veux
dire notre reconnaissance à ceux qui se
sont mobilisés pour soigner nourrir
éduquer protégé à tous ceux qui par leur
travail leur engagement nous ont permis
de tenir debout et ensemble durant ces
mois difficiles et qu'ils se soient
encore le font pour la nation à nos
concitoyens oeuvrant dans les secteurs
de la culture du sport de la
restauration de l'hôtellerie du tourisme
ou de l'événementiel aux étudiants
qui ont souffert et souffre encore
davantage que les autres je veux leur
redire que nous serons là évidemment
pour réussir à sortir au plus vite de
cette situation et pour leur permettre
de tenir dans cette période si dures et
injustes pour eux ou nous leur demandons
de travailler autrement et parfois même
de renoncer à leur activité
cette épreuve historique a aussi révélé
la solidité de notre nation malgré la
pandémie
nous n'avons jamais renoncé à poursuivre
notre ambition de progrès pour chacun en
baissant les impôts en ouvrant de
nouveaux droits comme le congé pour les
aidants l'allongement du congé paternité
en soutenant par des primes la
conversion de notre parc automobile en
ouvrant sur tout le territoire des
maisons france et rvices en investissant
dans notre souveraineté et notre
recherche de manière historique en
agissant pour produire davantage en
france en europe nos soignants ont non
seulement tenu mais nous avons engagé
une transformation en profondeur et d
investissement historique pour notre
santé dans les prochaines années
révéleront la pertinence notre pays est
l'un de ceux qui est le plus intervenu
pour protéger et accompagner les jeunes
les travailleurs les entrepreneurs ce
quoi qu'il en coûte
je l'assumé car il a permis de préserver
des vies et de protéger des emplois
il nous faudra bâtir ensemble les
réponses qui permettront de ne pas en
faire un fardeau pour les générations
futures
ce soir pour la première fois un pays le
royaume uni quittera l'union européenne
nous avons scellé il ya quelques jours
un accord pour organiser nos relations
futures avec lui en défendant nos
intérêts des industriels
nos pêcheurs et notre unité européenne
le royaume uni demeure notre voisin mais
aussi notre ami est notre allié ce choix
de quitter l'europe
ce break site
a été l'enfant du malaise européen et de
beaucoup de mensonges et de fausses
promesses mais je veux moi vous dire
très clairement ce soir notre destin est
d'abord en europe notre souveraineté
nationale et je ferai tout pour que nous
retrouvions la maîtrise de notre
destinée et de nos vies mais cette
souveraineté passe aussi par une europe
plus forte plus autonome plus unis c'est
ce que nous avons bâti en 2020 parce que
nous avons su conduire les
transformations nécessaires et renforcer
notre crédibilité nous avons su
convaincre l'allemagne puis les autres
membres de l'union européenne de
concevoir un plan de relance unique est
massif et de décider d'un endettement
commun et se libère pour mieux préparer
notre avenir en nous engageant dans la
transition écologique et numérique et en
créant autant d'emplois que nous le
pouvons pour notre jeunesse
oui cette année 2020 ne se résume pas à
l'épidémie
même si celle ci a changé nos vies elle
a aussi à mes yeux révélé des parcours
exemplaires qui sont autant de boussole
pour les temps à venir
notre plus grande fierté en effet ce
sont les françaises et les français vous
marie corentine à 24 ans au printemps
dernier cette infirmière fraîchement
diplômés originaire de limoges n'a pas
hésité à tout quitter pour prêter main
forte aux équipes de l'hôpital de
créteil débordées par l'afflux des
malades du virus
jean luc et chauffeurs éboueurs en
guyane avec ses collègues anthony et
maxime
ils n'ont jamais cessé de travailler
depuis le début de la pandémie au plus
fort du confinement il constituer cette
deuxième ligne qui a permis au pays de
continuer à vivre et à la vie de
continuer gérald et entrepreneurs près
d'angers pour faire face à la demande de
masques
il a avec ses salariés réussi la
prouesse d'ouvrir ses usines 7 jours sur
7 24 heures sur 24 et plus récemment
d'en installer une autre en un temps
record
le cas à 11 ans 11 ans et habite béthune
lorsqu'il a découvert la situation
d'isolement des personnes âgées
atteintes du coc vide 19 dans l'hôpital
de sa ville
il n'a pas hésité une seconde et a fait
don de sa tablette pour leur permettre
de communiquer avec leurs proches et de
retrouver le sourire
il a été suivi par de nombreux autres
rosalie et libraires à bagnolet en
seine-saint-denis
comme tous ses confrères elle a beaucoup
souffert de la fermeture des commerces
malgré les aides
elle a su innover mettre en place un
site internet pour permettre la vente à
emporter lors des semaines les plus durs
il est client à noël ont répondu présent
romain et gendarmes attendent dans les
alpes maritimes la nuit du 2 au 3
octobre
des inondations menace d'emporter une
maison de retraite au péril de sa vie
il parvient à évacuer plus de 70
résidents leur sauvant la vie avec les
policiers de nice qui ont mis fin à
l'attentât de la basilique notre dame de
l'assomption avec arnaud cyril et rémy
gendarme tué alors qu'il portait secours
à une femme battue dans le puy de dôme
avec ta mairie d'orient et quand un
militaire mort lundi dernier en
opérations au mali
ils sont des héros de la nation mehdi et
professeur de sciences économiques et
sociales dans les quartiers nord de
marseille
comme des milliers d'enseignants il a eu
quelques jours après l'assassinât de
samuel patty a organisé un cours sur la
laïcité
pour cela il a pris le temps de se
former auprès d'autres professeurs et
inspecteurs d'académie et avec courage
il est alors revenu auprès de ses élèves
sur nos valeurs
leur histoire assumant cette haute
mission de notre école de nos
enseignants faire des républicains wendy
et footballeuses comme tous les sportifs
amateurs et professionnels elle a vécu
une saison difficile avec des
entraînements impossible des
compétitions décalé des matchs sans
public pourtant elle à puiser en elle la
force d'âme d'aller remporter avec son
club de toujours
une septième ligue des champions un
record est de nous faire rêver dans
cette perte
degryse morissette à 60 18 ans elle
réside dans une maison de retraite de
sevran et il ya quelques jours
vous l'avez tous vu comme moi elle a été
la première française à se vacciner
contre la copie de 19 ans voyant contre
l'obscurantisme et le complotisme un
magnifique message d'espoir pour l'année
qui s'ouvre
tous ces prénoms ces visages sont ceux
de votre soeur de votre voisin de vos
amis de ces milliers d'anonymes qui
engage et solidaires ont tenu notre pays
dans l'épreuve
tous ces prénoms ces visages sont ceux
de l'espérance ceux de france mes chers
compatriotes notre nation a traversé
cette année avec une telle unité et une
telle résilience rien ne peut lui
résister notre nation a été capable dans
ces temps difficiles de temps
d'innovation d'inventivité de générosité
tout lui est possible en 2021
quoi qu'il arrive nous saurons donc
faire face aux crises sanitaires
économiques et sociales terroriste
climatique qui ne s'éteindront pas avec
le 1er janvier les premiers mois de
l'année seront difficiles et au moins
jusqu'au printemps
l'épidémie pèsera encore beaucoup sur la
vie de notre pays
en 2021 quoi qu'il arrive parce que nous
nous y sommes préparés nous saurons
aussi relever les défis à venir
la transition écologique et la
protection de la biodiversité avec la
mise en oeuvre des propositions de la
convention citoyenne et d'autres
réformes
la lutte pour la république et pour nos
valeurs
la laïcité la fraternité pour plus de
sécurité et la poursuite de notre
engagement pour le mérite le travail
l'égalité des chances et la lutte contre
toutes les inégalités et contre les
discriminations
les épreuves que nous avons affrontée
aurait pu émoussé notre enthousiasme
désaltérer l'espoir il n'en est rien
l'espoir est là
l'espoir est là dans ce vaccin que le
génie humain a fait advenir en un an
seulement
c'était impensable il ya encore quelques
mois et je vous le dis avec beaucoup de
détermination ce soir je ne laisserai
personne jouer avec la sûreté et les
bonnes conditions encadrés par nos
scientifiques et nos médecins dans
lesquelles la vaccination doit se faire
et je ne laisserai pas davantage pour de
mauvaises raisons
une lenteur injustifiée s'installer
chaque français qui le souhaite doit
pouvoir se faire vacciner de manière
sûre et dans le bon ordre en commençant
par ceux qui présentent le plus de
risques
l'espoir est là et l'espoir grandit
chaque jour dans cette relance qui déjà
frémit en france plus qu'ailleurs et qui
va nous permettre dès le printemps
d'inventer une économie plus forte
tout à la fois créatrice d'emplois plus
innovantes plus respectueuses du climat
et de la biodiversité et plus solidaire
et je sais le premier ministre et le
gouvernement pleinement mobilisés
l'espoir vie dans la liberté que nous
retrouverons dans la force de notre
culture de notre art de vivre à la
française dans les leçons aussi que nous
saurons tirer de cette crise pour plus
de simplicité d'efficacité parfois tout
simplement de bon sens
l'espoir vie dans notre jeunesse nous
lui avons tant demandé des sacrifices de
renoncer aux rencontres qui sont à cet
âge plus qu'à d'autres le sel de la vie
nous lui avons tant demandée pour sauver
des vies en particulier les vies des
plus fragiles de nos aînés nous sommes
donc ses débiteurs pour nos choix à
venir et je m'y engage
c'est pour notre jeunesse que nous
devons continuer à agir
à transformer à avancer n'ajouterons pas
au coût de la crise celui de l'inaction
en luttant contre le virus en nous
battant contre ses conséquences
économiques et sociales en refondant une
société plus forte fraternelle et
durable c'est la france de 2030 que nous
bâtirons telle est notre cap
alors ensemble dans la concorde
regardons devant nous regardons notre
avenir
préparons dès aujourd'hui ce printemps
2021 qui sera le début d'un nouveau
matin français d'une renaissance
européenne
restons ce peuple uni solidaire
fier de son histoire de ses valeurs de
sa culture
confiant dans l'avenir et le progrès sûr
de son talent et de son énergie et
ambitieux pour lui même quoi qu'il
arrive
soyons fiers fiers d'être nous les
français la france voilà mes chers
compatriotes
bonne année à tous que 2021 soit une
année heureuse pour chacune et chacun
est une année utile pour notre pays vive
la république et vive la france